yes you do and one of the one of the
hallmarks of breath work deep
mindfulness meditation and emdr
which i'm so grateful to have been able
to use all of those modalities but if
you can't for whatever reason find an
emdr specialist or you can't afford it
or insurance doesn't cover it breath
work is free and it it my doctor said
you didn't need the emdr for that memory
because the breath work was enough it
was sufficient that's my doctor saying
that we moved on to the next memory
because she determined that i had
already done what we were going to do in
the room so
that's the power of breath work and and
we we do put a lot of faith in our
doctors but every once in a while we get
an amazing doctor like my doctor
dr charlene rouhan and she
she by all means necessary healing she
doesn't care she doesn't have an ego
about it she just wanted me to heal and
she knew that this was going to be
something that i should do alongside of
emdr and i continued and do this day i
still do breath work i don't do emdr
anymore but i still do breath work have
you ever done any have you ever tried
any other modalities that include like
as an example i have a body worker um
here that i use she's amazing and
super spiritual super super into it like
she's lived in peru and done deities and
she's like very all there
um and you're definitely gonna hang out
i just want you to know i am like that's
official
i can't wait
we're i i i actually really believe that
will happen um sooner than later but um
and so i remember i had seen her for a
couple of years and she does amazing
body work she actually uses her feet to
walk on you
and to the massage so she does massage
but it's body work and there's you know
emotional and um energetic things
happening
and it was last year and it was kind of
just just before sort of my is just at
the sort of beginning of my big trauma
that happened last year and
uh she's like you know i can you know i
can feel you in a different place and
she's like you know if anything comes
through she's like just keep going i
keep going just kind of keep going
breathe through it whatever comes
through just just just just allow it and
so as she's doing some work and she's on
my back and she's on the spot and she's
like
eventually it's like the spot that won't
go away and she goes if this spot had a
sound what would it be
and so like the first one i gave it like
a little like it's so weird right i mean
all of it can be weird and uncomfortable
until this week i would say yes that's
weird but i've literally been a part of
a virtual sound healing summit and i'm
learning so much about the power of
sound and us
make using our voice to make those
sounds for release so i'm right here
with you yeah so she said give it a
sound and i was kind of like ah you know
i gave it a sound it wasn't a real one
and then a couple like 10 seconds went
by and all of a sudden like i made the
sound that all of a sudden just came out
and it was like much louder and bigger
and then i just started bawling wow
and so you're so right that like the the
sound and the audible like the somatic
element of things whether it's breathing
or some sort of verbal you know i mean
have you ever heard of taran toomey she
has the thing called
workout called the class um she
it's she has an app and she also has a
studio in new york but okay part of it
includes a lot of
verbal like so it's like you'll call
play a song and then in the song you do
the same movement over and over again
and in it there's encouragement to
make noise so you're like
you know you like really get it out and
what's crazy is that by the end of even
in the middle but definitely by the end
of it when it goes into like the heart
opening which is this just literally
move your arms back and forth all of a
sudden and verbal prompts help like
questions and things like that but i
mean like most of the time that i do it
it's like all there are tears for
something you know you're processing
something so
uh that's so cool that um you know
you've found techniques and and honestly
so young
well i mean you said it to you said it
about your your little i said your
daughter your your inner child i think
of my inner child as my daughter now but
you being being silent being silent for
so long right
of course we need sound of course we
need to find my i gotta you know when
they do those energy readings like the
auric field and your energy centers my
throat center my throat chakra was black
oh
wow yeah
oh wow it's a great response i was more
like oh wow
i was like i i've been doing this work
for a year i'm like wait i've been
working on myself for a long time what
do you mean my throat's still
what
i literally i i literally was
blown away by how many parts of my life
i started to realize because when that
stuff like that happens i ask myself
where am i being silenced where am i not
speaking my truth what i realized was i
wasn't being silenced anymore i was
speaking my truth very loudly
i did not know i was allowed to speak my
needs
speaking my needs
was a thing that i did not do especially
with men
i did not voice my needs and because of
that my throat was so blocked and sound
has been so profoundly healing and to
your point we're right on this parallel
wavelength but i was in this wild
amazing breath work that was facilitated
by e car wood who is a part owner of
modern nirvana which actually they're
having an amazing thing in austin texas
this weekend a convention with deepak
chopra and all those guys it's all all
of these modalities but he's a
breathwork facilitator and he did a two
and a half hour session with me
and i swear to god i saw the black
bubble thing in my throat
i literally i felt he he even got a
trash can i was like i'm so sorry like i
was like retching it was so intense
sorry guys if you're like really being
grossed out listening to this but it was
so powerful and so beautiful because
here's what's so crazy
he turned on a song and i knew the song
after like two hours of the session and
that had happened and i was coming down
from it and i started singing i could i
could sing like i i don't sing i sing in
the shower i sing in my car my
convertible top down with the wind
blowing he was like you're such a
beautiful singer you know do you do that
with your work and everything and i was
like no no ecar i i i don't i've never i
don't sing i don't know what that was
that was crazy but my something released
in my throat and
i like
now when i do sound modalities and stuff
i can move all the way up and down the
scales and i would always get these like
little blocks
so all of the everything the body keeps
the score it's actually a book by bessel
van impe yeah i bought that book just a
few weeks ago to to oh my god read it
yet but i i got it amazing amazing
amazing book life-changing for me and
for anyone who might have felt like it
was your fault that you froze during a
sexual assault or any kind of
any kind of abuses i i remember when i
was sexually assaulted when i was a
teenager out here in la my whole body
just froze and my system shut down and i
was reading the body keeps the score
i'll never forget i burst into tears
because it started talking about how the
system does a system override and sends
you into freeze we always hear about
fight or flight we don't hear about
freezing faint
he's unfaint oh [ __ ] fun or faint free
yeah you like you can lose consciousness
right so you can like you can you can
technically faint um but it's a it's a
psycho um you know not a psychosomatic
but um it's a psychologically induced
fainting yeah
but so my body learned to freeze i
breath work was really hard for me
because i never breathed i didn't my my
lungs were actually
incapable of full capacity because my
ribs were concave due to years of
holding my breath during my trauma these
are all things i learned by bodywork and
i'm so grateful again to my doctor for
not saying that western medicine is the
only answer she wanted to work with all
modalities because she wanted me to heal
did you ever well speaking of western
medicine versus eastern
were you on ever taking anything were
there any
were you on any kind of antidepressants
or anything ever
yeah i was diagnosed bipolar so my my
family has bipolar i recently had my
brain scanned by dr daniel amen who
believes that we shouldn't just sit
someone in a 30-minute session with a
psychiatrist and then start trying out
pills on them like they're a lab rat
we he said why do we have you come in
for a heart ekg if you have a heart
issue why do we have you come in to see
you know an ultrasound when you have a
stomach issue and then we just like you
know the brain it's not that important
of an organ we don't really need that
one so much as we need the other ones we
won't look at that and we'll just throw
chemicals your way and good luck i hope
it works out for you he's like i don't
understand this you need to see what
you're diagnosing before you diagnose it
so he scans brains for mental health
patients and he has an incredible book
called the end of mental illness which
is a little controversial the title but
it's pretty brilliant where he goes with
all of it that's amazing and you know
for people listening because i think
there are a lot of people taking
something and i don't want anyone to
feel like a loser or like you're doing
it wrong
i think you know i work with this lady
her name is elisa romeo she wrote a book
called meet your soul which is how i met
my soul and gave it a name she's lucy
but she she talked about
these kinds of medications in a way that
made a lot of sense to me because i
guess i would come from the other side
of like don't take it like deal with
your [ __ ] you know
suck it up or you know all those kinds
of things probably things that i
shouldn't be saying to myself anymore
but but
but i was like hmm
let's listen to this and she she said
that sometimes you're so depressed or
you're so sad and you're so in it so
much anxiety that you literally can't
choose a good thought
so for those holes that you're in where
you just can't get out and you can't
choose a good thought you have to it's
good to take something so you can start
to choose a good different thought so
you can start to
reprogram it's almost like a
neuroplasticity phase where you're like
oh like really it's a hundred percent
patterning yourself in a different way
and the idea is to get off of them but
in the beginning if you can't get out of
the hole and choose a good thought that
they can be really helpful to
re-patterning and to getting on the
right track absolutely you know some
people so many people no but i
experienced both sides because i was put
on lamechtol i was put on a mood
stabilizer after being diagnosed with
bipolar because i was in a depression
that i could not get out of and for that
exact purpose and because you're all
into the brain
when we do something repetitively the
brain learns it the brain learns
depression the brain learns anxiety it
repeats it because it's experiencing it
over time
so to unlearn it we do need assistance
and if modalities like breath work and
and meditation and all of these things
aren't they aren't cutting it or you're
not at that place where you're
interested in it yet whatever the case
may be because of the symptoms that i
had that were in alignment with bipolar
they were trauma induced because they've
been healed once
i got through my trauma so i couldn't
really have bipolar if i no longer have
bipolar symptoms bipolar is seen as a
chemical imbalance which means it is
incurable unlike a personality disorder
or something that is alterable it is so
to be diagnosed as bipolar and then to
no longer show symptoms of bipolar with
no medication consistently for two and a
half years which is where i'm at now
there's there was a little something
going on with my psychiatrist diagnosis
yeah right well it's opening you know
you were a child and you know probably i
mean the the brain is the final frontier
we don't get it that's why there's a
million i interviewed neil degrasse
tyson and he's like whenever there's
someone writing a lot of books about
something it's because they don't get it
they don't know there's a lot of books
about consciousness in the mind and how
everything works but um but you know so
it's imaginable that you know as we
continue to discover that you know
there's
you know disassociative personality
disorder which is what you then were
which you which is what more actually
what you had versus bipolar right yes
right so split as a kid because you had
to be you couldn't be yourself so you
had to go be this other person and you
had to you just had to re-emerge that
remember i had to exactly i had to
integrate and and it's so you know i
think the i think the most important
thing for anyone who might be
experiencing this right now or or being
uncertain that you're experiencing it
because i didn't know i was splitting i
i i had the sense that i had bipolar
because i ticked all the boxes i had
hypersexuality
hyperspending or hyperfrugality i would
go i would swing between
impulsively spending to impulsively to
being really really like i'm not going
to park in a meter and drive around the
block 10 times to find it like i
literally i can afford a two dollar
meter i don't know why i'm tripping
um i had
like in you know um insomnia um
grandiosity
i don't know if the grandiosity went
away completely um
that one's that one's still my ego
working on that um but i ticked like
seven out of nine boxes and was
diagnosed with mild hippomania and what
bessel vanderkol talks about in that
book that you just got the body keeps
the score
is how he's fought for at that point
over 25 years with the
american psychiatrist association
to have them put in the diagnostic
statistics manual the manual that all
psychiatrists have to purchase
every couple five years or whatever it
is when they update it to put into that
book that trauma is something that
people have and that it should be looked
at when you're treating people and
giving them chemicals and putting them
in their bodies so i'm on both sides of
it i'm both grateful for the mood
stabilizer that absolutely i'm so
grateful i was on it when my memories
came back
because i did not go into what could
have been a really horrific downward
spiral due to the instability of the
patterns of my brain at that time
but then i retrained my brain through
all of the healing modalities i began
and by
november of 2000 and
was it 2019
yeah by november of 2019 so my memories
came back in august of 2018. by november
of 2019
i went off my medication with my doctor
i told i didn't go back to my
psychiatrist because he was already
trying to like have me go on something
else the more i told him i was doing
well he was like sure that it was my
grandiosity i was trying to put me on
different things i talked to my doctor
who's an actual phd and has a background
in neuroscience and knows the brain very
well so specializing in emdr which is
specifically a treatment of the brain
right
and she said let's watch how you do
and if
in
and then we went into 2020. i should
have had a lot of episodes going on in
2020 right i had
i i'm
exactly who's talking to you right now
as who i've been over the last year and
a half
all through this situation and that was
coming off of the medication finding
modalities that helped me that are free
and coinciding them with treatment that
thankfully i was able to you know have
insurance pay for
but now you know my maintenance is every
day i do that work and i i there's a
little thing that i um and i know we've
we talked to i just realized the time
i'm like god i could talk to you forever